I wish I could let go of some
forgiveness issues ah I wish I could let
go of looking back at what I haven't
done and not waste any more time on that
especially since I had breast cancer
this year so yeah fear of commitment
my desire for perfection and for people
my past relationship I suppose because
it's kind of affected me in every other
relationship I've ever been in
I guess that's a seems very cliche but I
guess that is the first thing that comes
to mind dead parla mm-hmm
money I feel like money just makes us
really complicated and everything will
be so much easier if we if money didn't
have a value for people and just society
in general
hmm
it's a deep question I even know you um
I have to pee I wish I can like let go
the needs have to do time school
it's really stressful and I wish we
didn't need so much schooling for one
bit of Education I would say certain
feelings towards my parents just for the
way things like played out in my life
and where I'm at now in relation to
decisions that they made I'm actually in
the process of doing that but I think a
lot of it has to do with the way you
view yourself as well like it's not just
about you know what their actions caused
but just like me taking responsibility
for myself I wish I could let go of my
anxiety you know just a Burnout ticking
fault for everything
body image I wish I could let go of body
image I think it holds me back and I
tried not to pass that on to my kids and
I wish I could let that go and I'm
working on it
so you see me out here being strong
that's me fighting my inhibitions to
think too much pride sometimes it's good
let go of my anger sometimes I wish I
could let go of my childhood my family
were immigrants in Australia and it was
they struggled and it was a really hard
life and it was just um I don't know
that was basically the crux of it
emotional baggage from the past you know
there's just so much that sort of
collects you know and sometimes you
don't realize it and sometimes you get
to recognize it and let it go and make
the load a lot lighter as you go forward
I wish I could they go off time election
it have like restriction in my life and
yeah just like go wherever I want to
whatever I want in you know like
countries having too much time indoors
and computer I I wish I could let go of
fear allowing the space to allow
mistakes to happen yeah in life
some reviewers forgiving myself being
shy here trying new things they're being
open my insecurities I want to let go of
Auto sabotaging myself I do that a lot
so I definitely want to do that I wanna
let go of that you know it's funny
because I have a really deep attachment
to San Diego itself like I love this
city and I have to move all the time
like I was in Jordan for two years now I
have to go to San Francisco and live
there and I I keep coming back and I
don't want to leave I wish I could not
love this place so much I wish I could
let go of some of the stuff in my life
[Music]
my husband is a I don't want to say
order but I'm gonna say possibly close
to that so he likes to get stuff so like
for instance like he would go to a
garage sale and he might have this great
conversation with somebody who in the
50s like did like some sort of
collecting of something I don't know and
then somehow we end up with him things
like that so we have a lot of stuff so I
would love to like have less stuff in my
life
I did the the Peace Corps a couple years
ago and that was it was a great
experience but pretty heavy too and I
think especially coming back to America
and then to France and like the the
Western world it was a rougher
transition to come back than to go there
and I think I kept a lot of baggage from
that whole experience like for example
in my host country there were a lot of
you know issues with girls and women I
was a teacher so we were working a lot
with the female students and there were
a lot of situations in their lives and
in the lives of women in Bennett in my
host country that we were we were
working on promoting positive changes
and promoting women's rights and and
awareness of children's rights and
things like that so it really became a
part of my worldview and I'm just
thinking about these things all the time
all the time and
it's yeah I I would like to be free I
want to keep those ideas it's important
to me to to promote women's rights and
feminism but all right so I want to keep
that but I would like it to be
motivating instead of feeling like a
caged and heavy and crushing me all the
time I wish I could let go of my fear of
vulnerability and had to sell myself but
it's okay to have feelings and open up
to people look alike I can't do that
very well I wish I could let go of my
future
what do you mean I don't know an SPG now
no that's just sounds cliche I wish I
could let go of my sarcasm so I can give
you better edge here I can give you a
better answer
I guess what are you looking for just
honesty honesty what do you think I let
go of anything right now and you
wouldn't have to carry around anymore I
gotta go okay I let go of the coins in
my pocket that the things that tie you
down I was just what I'd like to just
take my backpack and hike off and cross
the border and disappear but you can't
do that because you got your job got
your mortgage got your car payment you
got all your other commitments let go of
it all and go
[Music]